是84年的，
那个时候是家里很穷，
我妈妈一个人把我和弟弟拉扯大，
然后是含辛茹苦把我供上大学的，
然后我大学毕业以后去那个北京工作，
工作过程中前任老公离婚的原因是因为就是我在工作的时候，
我当总监，
然后工作挺好的，
现在来看的话，
应该是被潜规则了，
之前太小了，
那时候是三十几岁吧，
孩子也有了，
那时候我的老大才大班，
刚毕业，
我就选择了分手了，
选择分手以后就跟他在一起了，
后来才知道他是有家庭了，
后我捋一捋，
就是说你当时在北京的时候，
你已经有家庭了，
有孩子了，
但是你还是跟老板在一块儿了，
是不是对孩子给给前夫了，
对我就什么也没有都给他了，
然后你是多长时间才发现老板其实是有家庭的，
其实我在这个没有分手的过程中，
就隐约知道了隐约的感受，
但是没有证实，
但是我就是那个时候已经太上头了，
因为那个他也特别会特别会哄人那种，
我是那种就是其实自己应该过得很好了，
然后自己把自己的生活毁了，
到现在就是自己也特别被动，
那后来我是分手以后嘛，
然后跟他就是有了孩子，
我也没有要求他分手，
我就想就因为那个时候。
太上头了，
就感觉好像是那种他不行的那种，
因为我从小到大我就很缺爱，
然后毕竟老公就属于那种，
我们都是大学毕业嘛，
然后他属于那种非常老实本分，
非趁好的男人，
我就是错过了，
就现在看的话就是错过了，
但那个时候就是30岁出头，
那个时候年轻的时候根本就是什么也知不知道现在的情况就是什么呢？
我在五年前已经主动的提出分开了，
就是分开了嘛，
然后他当时的话是写了一个协议书，
然后协议书基本上就是关于孩子抚养费的事情，
是每年给20万，
给到了就是二二年中年我也没跟他要，
马上明年孩子上小学了，
我也没有没有这个房子，
没有房子的话，
我就跟他说给我付一个孩子的首付嘛，
因为他给我那点钱，
就是我也上不了班，
孩子小，
我怎么跟他要这个，
继续要这个抚养费，
现在就是说我家里边跟我弟弟来了，
就是到他的老家来了，
因为他人找不到了，
给打电话也没有人接，
然后呃，
发信息也没人回，
把我所有的手机号都拉黑了，
然后他的意思上次孩子过生日打电话打了，
打通了一次，
他的意思就是说他现在公司呢也是负债，
然后呢人在外地，
然后他的意思就是不行，
你就用法律来问题来解决，
然后我就想这法律问题可能也解决不。
不了这个事情，
因为他如果就是说把公司就运作好了的话，
咱们那个抚养费也要不回来，
然后我跟我弟弟现在就是在他老家呢，
昨天去到了他老家，
然后就是说，
因为我现在确实是一个是年纪大了，
也到40岁了，
41了，
工作又不好找，
然后还想钱又没有，
然后我就想着用孩子看看能不能把这个事情解决一下，
我就把孩子先放在他老家了，
我就先出来了，
然后昨天我就特别特别后悔，
之前觉得好像自己能做到，
但是就是这一晚上我也没有睡觉，
就是感觉没有孩子我不行，
我就想看看寻这边有没有什么办法帮我就是。
做做选择，
怎么去决定这个事情，
我脑子也比较乱，
第一，
你在有老公有孩子的情况下，
毅然决然的选择跟了这个当时的老板，
二，
你跟你这个老板也生了孩子，
但是他自始至终没有给你名分，
没有给你婚姻，
第三，
在这个过程当中，
他也没有给你很多的什么资产，
没有给你什么保障，
是吧？
你像现在40多岁了，
我问你，
你有啥？
你什么都没有，
没有房子，
现在是没有这个，
没有存产，
嗯，
也没有很好的工作是吧，
没有，
对，
现在你跟老板生的这个孩子是几岁，
现在是快6周岁了，
嗯，
快6周岁了，
你把一个刚刚6周岁的一个小孩儿放到这个老板家里，
是送给他老家，
老家就只有那个他爸爸妈妈，
但爷爷奶奶自始至终跟他也没有太深的亲缘关系，
等于是你把一个6岁的小孩儿放到了一个陌生的环境，
我感觉是那人，
哦，
真的，
就算，
就算你是我的粉丝，
就算你在我这花了钱，
我内心深处我对你啊。
你等于是现在想要你这个6岁的小孩儿在为你的人生错误在买单，
你知道吗？
你想用想要6岁的小孩去要挟对方，
想要用6岁的小孩去胁迫对方，
我就是昨天晚上我才意识到这个问题，
就是我就觉得自己这么说吧，
第一，
这一路走过来，
这一切是你自己的选择，
你要为自己的选择去买单，
今天这一切不是别人造成的，
嗯，
你如果说你16岁，
你18岁，
你不经人事，
你被老板骗了，
我同情你，
但是你是30多岁，
你结过婚，
你生过小孩儿，
你说你被老板骗了，
谁同情你？
这一切都是你自己自找的，
嗯，
这切都是你自己的选择带来的结果，
所以你要为自己的今天买单，
这是要抚养费，
这个事情确实啊，
该要可以要，
该打官司可以打官司，
这事儿你需要去拿出证据证明这孩子是老板的，
你需要拿出证据证明你和老板之间这些年牵扯不断的这个关系，
嗯，
然后你告诉他抚养费，
可能我告诉你也就是几千块钱，
你要想拿到一年20万的抚养费，
这个概率是比较小的，
不大可能的。
那么接下来就是以后你的人生到底应该怎么走？
到底应该靠谁？
你不要寄希望于说孩子长大了，
我靠孩子，
你的人生才40岁都还来得及，
只要你身体是健康的，
四肢是健全的，
能要能吃苦，
能拉得下脸，
能不要这张所谓的以前很风光的这张脸，
摆脱以前的人际关系，
摆脱以前的生活圈子，
你就琢磨一下，
我现在哎，
41岁了，
我只要身体健康啊，
素质健全，
我还能干点什么事儿，
自己能够挣到钱，
能够养活我和孩子，
你可千万啊，
注重自己内心的调节，
你不要认为说你今天人生这么悲惨，
好像是因为呃跟这个老板好了，
悲惨好像是因为生了这个孩子了，
悲惨不是你的人生，
就是今天，
就是你自己呃的选择造成的。
千万不要把你对生活的怨气，
对老板的恨意转嫁到孩子身上去，
嗯嗯嗯，
我其实对谁也没有恨，
我就现在确实就是，
呃，
我跟他在一起，
我也没有就是说像想象中的这个那样子，
就是他刚开始的时候，
我就刚开始的时候的时候，
他刚刚创业，
也没有钱，
在一起的时候也没有什么买过什么高档场所，
或者是买过名牌什么东西，
我都是他不如以前的生活条件，
现在就是说我没有，
就是说就生了这孩子，
我从来没有后悔过，
就是可能就是在心里面。
对这个事情的这个接受程度，
现在就是昨天还没有想开的，
今天我全都想开了，
因为今天我想了一整夜，
我觉得自己确实是因为我，
我可能就觉得我想赌一把，
因为有孩子嘛，
我就现在就最错误的就是我不应该用孩子来赌，
我本来就是计划孩子在那儿待个三四天，
他们家人肯定会给我打电话的，
但是我我觉得就是说我挺不到那那一天，
我是因为是昨天晚上孩子睡着了，
我走的，
我是想今天我就去给他接回来，
就是哪怕就是我什么我都不要了，
就是怕我还给我不行，
那些难自己想象一下，
一个孩子在陌生的环境下，
谁都不认识，
妈妈不在了，
他以为妈妈抛弃他了，
他得多难受，
就这事儿，
你做好这样的思想准备，
就哪怕说你自己一个人养孩子，
咱日子也得过呀，
我这是对我自己的挣钱能力，
还有就是往后的我是挺有信心的，
只不过就是。
跟孩子在一起，
我更多的是关注孩子，
因为之前他能给抚养费嘛，
我就想安心心的把孩子带好，
把他抚养成人长大，
全部精力都陪他，
但是现在可能没有那个条件，
我跟你说，
孩子需要的不是一个，
不是一个什么24小时都陪着他的妈妈，
孩子需要的是一个对生活充满着热情，
对生活充满着热爱的，
对自己以后的生活有着这个干劲儿的，
孩子需要的是这样的一个榜样，
这样一个妈妈。
我个人认为，
就算他一个月给你2万块钱，
这事儿，
你说你天天跟孩子呆在一块儿，
你就能培养出孩子很好吗？
未必，
嗯，
孩子要从你身上看到你的生命力，
看到你遇到困难的时候，
遇到挫折的时候，
看到你愿意去拼搏，
去奋斗，
看到你不管遇到什么事情的时候，
你没有抛弃他，
你没有舍弃他，
孩子需要的是这个你啊，
该起诉起诉，
该要抚养费，
要抚养费这事儿不耽误，
但是这个抚养费可能预心理预期的话，
就是几千块钱是几千块钱一个月还是他一年呢，
一个月，
一个月一个月就是2000块钱，
3000块钱，
这是比较常见的，
两三千块钱不要因为他那能能为就是他是从孩子就是分手以后，
分手以后就是应该都有五年，
五年期间吧，
从来没有看过孩子，
没有联系过孩子，
然后我就想如果就是真的去，
呃。
走法律程序的话，
能不能一次性的去结清抚养费啊，
这五年他一分钱都没给吗？
还是说人家也给钱呢，
只不过说这一年才没给钱，
因为这一年没给钱，
前两两年三年吧，
给钱呢？
哦，
你结结清的话，
你只能结清这一年没给的，
如果你俩之前有书面的协议写明白，
他一年要给20万抚养费的话，
这个在法律上是认的，
就是你你情我愿的事儿吗？
对，
你愿意给20万一年，
你有这个能力给20万一年吧，
你自己白纸黑字写下来给20万一年吧，
这个法院是认的，
但是你说一次性，
一次性给完的话，
什么情况下才会呃，
满足你的这个需求呢？
就是说男方那头啊，
都要出国了，
或者男方那头啊，
他经常玩儿失踪，
或者怎么怎么样，
你让那个法官去相信，
说，
哎呀，
这一把如果不给你一次性结清的话，
可能你再也找不着他要钱了，
你要让法官相信到这种程度，
才有可能给你一把结清，
否则的话都是按年按月，
但是他说跟我说，
他说已经负债了，
他说你愿意怎么告我怎么告我，
他现在是负债，
就算是负债的话，
该给孩子的抚养费啊，
一千两千的，
两千三千的还是得给，
就是钱不多，
你得节俭俭过日子啊，
嗯嗯，
那就这样，
你知道小孩哦，
小孩其实最害怕的事情就是被抛弃。
我不知道你们那个有没有同感，
还有很多人，
他可能小的时候被感受过被爸爸妈妈抛弃的那种感受，
他可能这辈子做噩梦都还会梦见那种状态。
其实小孩儿对他来说，
5块钱的煎饼果子和吃30块钱的麦当劳汉堡包对他来说的话，
那种幸福指数的区别不是很大，
但是对他无条件的这种爱，
无条件的他在你身边能够跟着你，
这件事情对他来说的的幸福指数影响非常大。